i'm charles payne i'm kat timf i'm
stuart varney and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday january 26 2022 i'm lisa brady
is american culture tilting in favor of
the criminals to me there's a real
reverse broken windows concept kicking
in where when you promote a culture of
lawlessness you get more of it and i do
think that that's a fair assessment of
what's happening in some of our big
cities
i'm dave anthony
north korea did it again
test firing more missiles in what's been
a barrage to start the year if north
korea feels it's being ignored it may
raise tensions because it feels that
that gives them leverage
and i'm guy benson i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
the white house is facing persistent
questions about rising crime and isn't
sugar coating the problem i think if we
look at the facts here we have seen a
surge of crime over the last two years
spokeswoman gensake blaming a few issues
gun violence is a huge reason for the
surge in crime
under funding of pulse and police
departments and their need for
additional resources something the
president has advocated for consistently
through the course of his career the
president has said more than once he's
not for defunding the police something a
number of cities have backtracked on as
crime has risen from mass smashing grab
attacks on retailers to carjackings and
shootings in atlanta this month alone
three children under the age of six have
been shot including a six-month-old baby
killed when a stray bullet hit a car
during a fight on tuesday a second new
york city police officer died from
friday's deadly confrontation during a
911 response the suspect who was also
shot and died this week had a criminal
history and multiple guns we need
washington to join us and act now
to stop the flow of guns
in new york city mayor eric adams has
released a blueprint to end gun violence
among other things urging state
lawmakers to give judges more
flexibility to deny bail for defendants
who could be violent the justice
department releasing a detailed report
on its efforts since last spring
including embedded atf agents with
police and sheriff's investigators in
dozens of communities
jim trustee is a former federal
prosecutor also a former assistant
states attorney in maryland
i think people should be concerned it's
certainly not universally
consistent across every jurisdiction
across every part of the country but
certainly in the urban centers in the
big cities we're seeing pretty horrific
spikes
in murder in particular violent crime in
general and i think we're also seeing a
lot of growing frustration with
progressive prosecutors and maybe
progressive legislators
that are making i think faulty decisions
when it comes to
bail reform
just to play devil's advocate for a
minute
is there any chance the media is
overreacting to you know a few numbers
in a few places
well i think if they want to say that
it's a national crime wave that's just
sweeping every single city in town then
sure that's over playing it but you know
you have to think a little bit about
what it would be like to live in a
chicago of philly and new york you know
in some of these areas where there's
some significant spikes in san francisco
and la to that
and i think for a lot of working class
folks that are just trying to get by day
to day it's a miserable existence when
they see that the culture kind of tilt
in favor of the criminals and of violent
crime and looting and all sorts of
things that seem to be held without
accountability right now
is that what is at the root of this kind
of a cultural tilt i mean how did we get
to this point
well look anybody that says they have a
perfectly scientific answer to any
change in crime rates is is kind of full
of it right i mean there's an awful lot
of factors and if anybody could figure
out the exact chemistry
to shut down crime you know they would
have already done that but
look i i do think that in
large cities the policies of the
politicians and the prosecutors and
maybe sometimes that's the same thing
that becomes common knowledge people
know that hey you can do a carjacking
and it's only going to get charged as a
felony theft or you can steal up to a
thousand dollars without any real
consequence you might get a citation but
you're not going to get fully prosecuted
so to me there's a real reverse broken
windows concept kicking in where when
you promote a culture of
lawlessness you get more of it and i do
think that that's a fair assessment of
what's happening in some of our big
cities
in let's take new york and l.a for
instance um two of the big cities where
local prosecutors have been accused of
you know letting certain things slide or
easing up on which cases they bring and
the potential punishments they've
started to push back on this kind of
soft on crime
image
are they getting too much of the blame i
know you're definitely saying it's it's
a key factor but are they getting
you know an oversized portion of the
blame
well i'm not sure about that i mean and
obviously there's kind of different uh
barometers within the media of how much
blame is
apportioned to these folks but you know
look they've been pretty unabashedly
radical in their approach to law
enforcement and you know not only does
the word get out that certain crimes
won't be treated the same way or people
will be released back into the community
but you demoralize the actual
enforcement part you demoralize
the police you demoralize the career
prosecutors that aren't just there to
make a headline or you know find a
higher political office and so you start
to see an accompanying brain drain you
know whether you're talking about
detroit or minneapolis or philly or new
york you start to see some of the senior
ranks of the prosecutors and of the
police leave and that hurts the
institutions too i think chicago might
be the best example of that under
kimberly fox
as a state's attorney they are losing
people that know
what practices work know how to try
cases know how to work with the police
and they're replacing them with
ideologues that don't get traction with
the rest of the law enforcement
community
presidents certainly can get the blame
for a lot of things too kind of comes
with the job
how much does federal
policy impact
local crime rates though or does it
well i think it does on the periphery
and maybe there's ways to have a more
positive influence in stopping crime i
mean you know in the old days go back 20
30 40 years federal prosecutors were not
viewed as ones that tackle violent crime
much at all it was viewed as a local
problem where the state prosecutors
dealt with that but what we've seen in
kind of recent decades is that the state
systems are overmatched sometimes
there's too many cases coming through
the system there's too much violence
there's too much witness intimidation
and all of that led to federalizing
violent crimes so you see more and more
u.s attorney's offices that are willing
to do gun cases to do drug cases to do
rico cases that they might not have been
as uh interested in 30 or 40 years ago
so
with that is an impact i think it's
largely a positive impact when the u.s
attorney's offices and i certainly did
this when i was an assistant in maryland
when they started doing a ricoh case to
go after the leadership of somebody like
ms-13 then you have a better chance of
actually hurting the organization as a
whole
and not just taking off kind of easily
replaceable soldiers so i i think the
federal practice can expand to be
a little bit more oriented towards some
of the violent crime in these places
like philly and l.a and chicago and in
fact that's probably good for moving the
needle back against some of the violent
crime in these big cities
is the justice department under
attorney general merrick garland on the
right track in this regard or are they
making it you know more difficult to
fight crime around the country
i don't know if they're making it more
difficult but i don't see a lot of help
i mean when you have these high profile
moments where it seems like civil rights
is the only part of doj that has the uh
imprimatur of the attorney general you
know what you're seeing is that
federalizing supervision of police
departments doubling up on civil rights
cases so i i haven't seen much i mean
i've read through some of the doj
announcements of what they're doing
about violent crime and it tends to be a
little bit more of the midnight
basketball kind of approach that we need
to come up with you know re-entry
programs and things to keep youth out of
trouble and it's not that those are
necessarily bad ideas they're they're
holistic part of all of this maybe but
not much that really gets down to the
deployment of troops you know getting
people out on the streets to work with
the locals and try to improve the
quality of life for the people that are
victimized in these neighborhoods
when it comes to quality of life and the
types of crimes that really attract the
headlines a lot of it is gun violence of
the new york city mayor eric adams
former cop announced his new plan this
week including more officers on patrol
also saying he wants to appoint an
anti-gun violence coordinator
in every city agency is is this kind of
focus on gun violence should that be
more of a national focus
yeah i'm a little torn on that to tell
you the truth i mean certainly a lot of
the murders and a lot of the armed
criminal activity that takes place is at
gunpoint i get that but it's kind of
this bizarre distancing from the actual
conduct to only refer to it as gun
violence it's people using guns it's
gang members it's flash mob moments
where
people just you know take offense and
start engaging in violence it's road
rage i mean there's all sorts of really
kind of pathetic excuses for violence
that break out across this country and
maybe the gun makes it easier to carry
out that violence but you know i'm kind
of hesitant to just put it all into this
category of what we call gun violence if
they're talking about using the atf to
be smart to try to track any patterns of
where guns are coming from how they're
ending up in places you know that's
never a bad idea
but i think at some point you have to
have some pretty rigorous enforcement of
the existing gun laws coupled with a
strong approach towards pre-trial
release when it comes to acts of
violence and
that's what i'm concerned about is that
people charged with acts of violence get
right back out in the community and it's
not just that they shouldn't be out it
means there's going to be a new victim
the new york mayor did also call for
more state and federal help
what would help in your opinion not just
in a big city but anywhere in the
country and and if for instance a
department you know does get let's say
more state or federal funding
how would that money best be used to try
and prevent crime
yeah that's a great question i mean i
think there's a couple of things you
know to stop the existing problems with
crime there's no substitute for bodies
you know to have atf or fbi safe street
task force agents that are working side
by side and kind of a task force
approach
to to head off street violence and to
make neighborhoods safer and so
i never uh you know
looked down my nose at the idea of
having deployments where
big cities you know pinpoint the worst
crime areas and have federal agents come
in and help out and take some of those
cases federally i also am a big fan this
is partly my own background at the
organized crime section of the
racketeering approach the rico approach
use the tools we use against the mafia
federally to go after the organized
street gangs and then yeah the federal
dollar is always
superior to what the state resources are
and so to the extent they can invest in
things like pre-trial services to have
some options of supervision instead of
just straight personal recognizance and
to focus also on the back end on
re-entry on prisoners you know this is
kind of the morgan freeman getting out
of shawshank that the prisoner that's
been locked up for a long time is going
to go back into the community and giving
them some tools and options to to make
it is not a terrible idea either and i
think that would affect the crime rate
on some level too
one other thing jim do you think that
we're
going to be headed in a better direction
anytime soon on this issue of crime even
just from the standpoint that now
there's a lot of attention
focused on it and a lot of people you
know saying they're concerned about it
a good question i don't know that
attention is enough to
move the needle in any direction i think
we're looking at a pretty tough spot i
think there's some real societal
breakdown in some places and the
reaction from particularly progressive
prosecutors and from legislatures that
you know are dealing with the difficult
issue of jail overcrowding but maybe
dealing with it in a clumsy way
those are all factors that are i think
combining to create problems on the
streets and the demoralization of police
in big cities
uh feeling that they don't have support
watching you know police bodies fall on
a daily basis across this country i mean
all that kind of demoralization of the
police seeps out to prosecutors it seeps
out to the good citizens that want to
see crime shut down and
they have a negative effect so i i don't
see us kind of getting out of this
problem anytime real soon
former federal prosecutor jim trustee we
always appreciate your time
sure thanks for having me
[Music]
this is guy benson with your fox news
commentary coming up
while the u.s and our allies all worry
about russia and if it will invade
ukraine
north korea is back at it launching more
missiles into the sea tuesday a fifth
round of tests this month alone
something that is profoundly
destabilizing it's dangerous and it
contravenes a whole host of u.s security
council resolutions that's what
secretary of state anthony blinken told
msnbc on january 13th as the u.s imposed
new sanctions blinking says months ago
they reached out to north korea we made
clear that we were prepared to uh to
engage the north koreans to sit down
with no preconditions to see if we could
find a way forward with them at the
table
toward the total denuclearization of the
korean peninsula but the only response
they've gotten is these tests and a
warning of more to come in a standoff
over the north korean nuclear weapons
program it's unusual in that it's almost
the record high number of missile
launches in a month bruce klingner is a
former cia deputy division chief for
korea a senior fellow for northeast asia
at the heritage foundation we often
debate why north korea has done a
missile test and it can be part of
winter military training it could be
developmental testing particularly for
those missiles which have not yet been
deployed it could be operational testing
of missiles that have only recently been
deployed and they're still testing uh
their viability
or particularly when we get to the
longer range missiles or certainly
nuclear tests they also seem to have a
message to either south korea or the us
right so here we with five in a month
you assume there's a message being sent
even then even and they haven't even
been shy about that i mean they they're
now even warning that they could
restart
activities
that had been put on hold or suspended
so what is that
and what could that mean
right well the the message last week
from north korea was it was a bit vague
but if you read between the lines it's
clear that it's a an indirect threat to
resume nuclear and or icbm testing uh
which they haven't done since 2017. so
this month's missile launches along with
a lot of others really are part of a
trend in the last
five years or so where
they've done a lot of missile testing in
2017 they did icbms and nukes
and then after that they did a lot of
short and medium range missiles
in 2019 they did 26 launches the most
ever in a year
revealing five new short and medium
range systems uh 2020 they did
some more launches
last year they did only about six or so
launches but in doing so they revealed
five new five yet more new systems so
north korea is not going to comply with
numerous un resolutions requiring it
to not only not do any missile testing
or nuclear testing but they also require
north korea to abandon these programs so
north korea is is continuing me
continuing to be defiant of the the
international community's requirements
for north korea to denuclearize well
they don't seem to ever care about
things like that back when president
biden took office
it was unclear and unsure exactly how
north korea would deal with the new
administration and there was that
warning from
from kim jong-un's sister
telling the u.s if we want to sleep in
peace
that we better refrain from causing a
stink
they seem to be upset about sanctions
that have been recently put on north
korea so what did we do
well i'd say north korea tends to use a
u.s or south korean action as an excuse
for doing things that they were going to
do anyway
but recently the bite administration
sanctioned six north korean entities and
two russians uh for helping north korea
get uh technology or components
for their missile program uh from
outside of north korea so it's you know
long overdue it's it's what i see as a
minimalist uh sanctions but successive
administrations have all underachieved
even on fully enforcing u.s laws so uh
it's a good step forward but there's a
lot more entities particularly chinese
that we could be going after
one thing that has been
talked about in the last year or two
with missiles is this hypersonic
technology the us and russia and china
are working on
has north korea perfected that
right well folks are really
attentive to the hypersonic name
and actually any ballistic missile that
goes more than about 300 miles is going
hypersonic five times sound
isn't there something that's a
characteristic to this technology where
it's it it's tougher to
shoot down and it's tougher to detect
and things like that
exactly so it's not so much the speed
it's the trajectory and the maneuverable
warhead so by having this kind of
missile it's sort of like a cruise
missile it flies low and closer to the
earth so having this flatter trajectory
uh
allied radar is
has a harder time to identify and track
it and then also
the warhead is maneuverable so it could
be able to evade uh allied missile
defenses now it is different from a
hypersonic test that china did uh last
year where that actually did an orbit
around the us or i'm sorry around the
world
and then fired all the way back to a
target in china so what that has caused
concern about is experts said well
anytime china launches a satellite
perhaps it's one of these hypersonic um
weapons so
so the north korean weapon is worrisome
but it's not as
capable as the chinese missile
president trump took a different
approach to north korea first threats
and insults rocket man
is on a suicide mission for himself
and for his regime telling the u.n
general assembly in 2017 if we have to
defend ourselves or our allies we will
have no choice but to totally destroy
north korea then it was talks and
compliments months later the president
took up kim jong-un's invitation to meet
and in june 2018 they held the first
ever u.s north korean summit really very
positive i think better than anybody
could have
expected top of the line and while the
president hailed a joint statement that
he and kim signed on denuclearization
the talks broke down and president trump
walked out of their second summit a year
later
it failed
you know i think the problem was
going to the summits prematurely there
there weren't sufficient progress
towards a denuclearization accord
before we had the summits the mind
administration has gone back to what's
been traditional
u.s policy of
uh conditioning any kind of summit
meeting on actual progress towards a
denuclearization agreement that's that's
what we did with the soviets on arms
control and what had been the approach
towards north korea before i think
that's the way to do it you have to get
into you know very detailed negotiations
uh to to try to prevent any more
loopholes and in the past the agreements
we've had with north korea were very
short very vague uh very poorly crafted
uh in that you could drive a truck
through some of the loopholes so i think
you know we don't want to shut the door
on diplomacy you know we've had eight
failed agreements with with the
international community with north
korean denuclearization that's not to
say we don't try for a ninth uh but
hopefully we we you know learn from the
stakes or the lessons of the past i'm
sure kim jong-un knows what's going on
around the world he sees this standoff
at the ukraine border that the us is
very much involved in he sees the china
taiwan tension that the u.s is involved
in he saw what happened in afghanistan
he's sort of down the list of worries
right now for president biden is he
trying to go up that list or is he
trying to just be an annoyance what's
what do you think you know usually if
north korea feels it's being ignored it
may raise tensions because it feels that
that gives them leverage uh and usually
they did a
a
strong provocation like a nuclear test
or an icbm test uh the first year of a
new u.s
administration so they did that with
bush and obama and trump they didn't do
it last year with biden and it may be
because of cobit if these large-scale
provocations are designed to push the us
back to the negotiating table in a
weaker way well right now their
diplomats can't leave the country
to meet with u.s counterparts because
they can't go back into the country
north korea has very strict uh covet
restrictions right now in fact they have
two
ambassadors to china because the one
that was replaced can't go back into
north korea the north koreans have
claimed kova never got there that they
don't have any cases that
that's uh that's a country that the
virus somehow ignored nobody really
believes that right
no it it's you know they're surrounded
by countries with high levels of of
covid um but they must have kept it down
to a certain degree with these very
draconian you know restrictions uh
because we had thought that if coveted
got into north korea it would just
spread like wildfire because the the
entire populace is is already emaciated
malnourished
you know
very weak uh physically and they have a
very poor health you know
industry there or hospitals so we had
thought that if it got into the country
that just we'd see massive uh you know
infections but
you know from what we can tell although
it's harder to get information from
north korea now you know we're there's
certainly cases but it's not really the
the epidemic that that we had thought it
might be
now you have referenced nuclear tests a
couple years ago they made a big
international display
of of them like looking like they were
destroying a missile a nuclear test site
in the attempt to show that they're
they're working toward uh diplomacy or
something
was that real
well what they did was they they blew up
the entrances to the tunnels under a
mountain they had a lot of test tunnels
under the mountain and without any
international inspectors there they just
brought in some outside journalists who
never got uh close to the to the attics
the entrances uh so they closed the
entrances
but they didn't do anything to destroy
the tunnels themselves now experts have
thought that the their very large
hydrogen bomb test
may have weakened the structure of the
mountain to such a degree that
another one of that size could have
brought the mountain down we don't know
but um you know it was trying to get
credit for for something that really
wasn't that big a deal
okay
what's next what do you expect next as
we get through the next month and
through the rest of this year
well even though north korea has has
threatened to do the nuclear and missile
tests i i think things are going to be
more of a continuation of the status quo
it doesn't look like we're going to have
diplomacy
i would think we're not going to have a
nuke or a missile test for a while i
think we're going to continue
possibly a high level of short medium
range missile testing i i would think
they would wait on the big ones until
they first had some more of these
statements hostile language increasing
sort of you must give us what we want or
we will do something bad
before they go to play their sort of
whole card of the new catastrophic icbm
now i could be wrong we could see that
tomorrow but i think it's going to be
more of the short medium range testing
for a while
bruce klinger former cia deputy division
chief for korea now senior research
fellow for northeast asia at the
heritage foundation as always good to
talk to you thank you so much
well thanks for having me again
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it on demand from fox news and
amazon alexa rate and review the fox
news rundown on apple podcasts or
wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
guy
what's on your mind the exhausting
relentless coven 19 pandemic is still
underway but there are some signs of
hope writing in the new york times
journalist david leonhardt notes three
trends first plunging cases in some of
the parts of the country hit hardest by
omicron we've seen this in south africa
in the uk as well a huge spike and then
a precipitous drop that drop is now
happening in the united states second
the risk of severe outcomes or death
from omicron is substantially lower than
previous variants we've already known
this to be true but the data continues
to confirm it it is less deadly and
third vaccines and boosters do appear to
continue to provide protection against
severe outcomes and death from covent
even if the vaccinated are not immune
from transmitting or contracting omicron
these are all hopeful signs in the uk
the government is lifting mass mandates
across the board at long last normalcy
might finally be returning to the united
states if only our leaders and so-called
experts will allow it this is guy benson
host of the guy benson show
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
new from the fox news podcasts network
my name is kennedy and welcome to my
podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome it's kennedy saves the world
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com